what is the most common misconception
that the average person has about
chemistry the misconception is pretty
simple they think that chemicals are
nasty toxic horrible what really winds
me up is when I see reports about bad or
evil or nasty chemicals and that somehow
everything in nature is good I think the
biggest misconception about chemistry
comes from the idea that a lot of people
have that chemicals are bad for you that
everything that chemists make is somehow
poisonous a chemical is a chemical it
doesn't matter whether it was made in a
natural process or whether it was made
in a glass flask or a metal reactor the
issue is what does it do to a human and
can a human tolerate it and I've got
some examples to prove that point was in
fact you are made entirely of chemicals
so my sodium chloride is table salt we
all need some of it to stay alive but if
you have too much of it in you it will
kill you we all need water to live most
of our bodies are composed of water but
if you drank too much water in one go
you would also end up killing yourself I
think it's important to realize that
everything in the world everything that
we can touch see feel is a chemical and
I think people forget that a lot of
times and that the word chemical has
become a bad word so it's not that
chemicals are good or bad it's just what
do we as people have tolerance for
that's actually their the key issue you
cannot have anything that exists without
it containing chemicals the Royal
Society of Chemistry has an offer that
if you can produce anything that you can
hold in a hat your hands that doesn't
contain chemicals they'll give you a
million pounds